[Music]
not a selling point also this is
Benjamin's box of plot specific trinkets
time long feared that this movie would
start with narration shucking corn
immediately after picking it instead of
waiting to shuck it until right before
cooking it because movie believes the
audience is too dumb to identify
uncooked corn as corn and to that I say
shuck you movie question why build a
fence around your house if you're going
to leave gaps this why this is jest the
fence is only decorative but this is pre
American Revolution when time would 100%
be better spent on crops animals and
general chores over building a giant
functionless decorative fence these kids
are addicted their family's crops we're
closing in on two minutes of these
characters reacting to the mail to be
fair this is the same reaction I have to
that little red one appearing on the
icon for my email client main character
is terrible at building rocking chairs
cliche wait what rocking chairs were
common pieces of furniture until the
early 1800s why not have been failed at
making tables turn on rocking
era-appropriate chairs expositional
breeding Mel Gibson's character has a
dead wife girlfriend daughter cliche so
what was in the mail roland emmerich
throws audiences a curveball by making a
film without a bad father sure he's
overbearing but Mel's clearly playing a
good and loving father in this movie and
let's just say everyone has an off day
even roland emmerich this list of names
is not in alphabetical order though they
do start out that way for about four or
five names he's 17 and year younger than
I oh the late 1700s when eighteen year
old males still had to ask her parents
permission for the CGI probably look
great when this movie came out but
that's the thing about CGI is it the age
is faster than an NFL running back
I support cleavage just as much as the
next guy but I have to point out this
movie put this nice lady and the other
support female characters and dresses
that would be considered quite revealing
for the time huge what have you been
feeding them well they're from good
stock on their mother's side of course I
realize his wife's been dead three years
and he's probably horny but in movie
time this is considered moving too fast
whooping Charlotte has presents for her
sister's kids upon their arrival for the
big Revolutionary War book happy maybe
we all dive out kids here's a ball in a
cup game and he put the CD Telegraph's
feature love story via accidental
bumping a time-honored tradition this
Howard is me you know who I am Gabriel
Martin the last time you saw me I was 11
and you put ink in my tea
if you were 11 last time Heather if you
recognize each other this time even had
this conversation
you sing 18 which means she's at least
16 year old and this is colonial America
not a daily Facebook update Society so
they should have much more trouble
recognizing each other and our rights
are being threatened by a tyrant 3,000
miles away hmm South Carolina to the UK
it's actually nearly 4,000 but maybe
you're rounding down by the thousand the
levy past at basically a two-to-one
differential this hanging around outside
the courthouse to hear about the vote
contingent is apparently 100 percent per
levy as there is one person in this show
that appears upset or sad do you intend
to invoice for that my from me well he
is a legal adult seems like only
yesterday when we last saw each other in
Charlestown letter-writing not so
cleverly disguised as narration snooping
while axe fingering guns and cannons are
going off and Benjamin doesn't demand
that his children go back inside the
house they'll probably kill us when I do
lord knows what do you wanna what
stop Tommy Tommasino has some tough
near-future fantasies I mean who even
thinks about this Jesus and I'm supposed
to be happy each time he gets saved in
this movie oh yeah
as I watched this panning shot of
Revolutionary War action from afar
I am in awe this might be the single
finest thing Roland Emmerich has ever
filmed as a 2 credits shy history minor
Bravo sir to syndra moon this would be
creepy if I hadn't already seen a second
drastic park movie British decide to
send all their available troops to the
area to finish off the 12 wounded
soldiers from last night's battle all
slaves of the American colonies who
fight for the crown will be granted
their freedom we're not slaves
I think it's worth noting that most
South Carolinians with wealth of the
time own slate the fact that the hero of
this movie is an outlier who does not
seems a bit of a script coincidence
rebel dispatches sir they were so poorly
hidden in this humongous house that I
found them in seconds also goddamn me
Fletcher's character hide that important
when you show up at home or tell your
dad to hide it Jesus come god damn it
you kept up the ruse all this way only
to ruin it with an impulsive father
this kid is stupid as hell and honestly
the entire rest of the movie including
Mel's involvement is due to this kids
stupidity you could argue that as this
movie presents things the Americans
would have lost their war for
independence at this one South Carolina
guy's kid hadn't so foolishly gotten
himself
luckily for Ben none of his weapons were
damaged in that fire not only that he's
able to walk out of the house like it
isn't even on fire hopefully this is a
sign that the Martins can still live in
their house and peacefully coexist with
the fire this rescue was badass and it
makes sense yes farmer in 1776 would
have taught his sons to shoot and yes he
would definitely know the nearby terrain
better than the British I'm taking one
cent off goddamn it I don't know a lot
about guns but I would assume these
rifles would be challenging to aim yes
Benjamin and his two sons continue to
shoot dead every one of their targets
it's like they're anti stormtroopers
these British troops are adhering to the
fight the good guy one of the time rule
that all bad guys must adhere to in
every movie that will be made until the
end of time if you look up over till in
the video dictionary this clip comes up
immediately and hey let's count the X
blow these levels on this fool shall we
just for posterity one two three four
five too many
[Music]
and childhood trauma counseling as an
industry what's Leslie born also this is
Roland Emmerich's first rated our film
since Universal Soldier and it's
basically just for this one scene I
think there's some more violence later
blood but no boobs or f-bombs or even s
bombs is s bombs I think cuz it should
be even if it's not this mother they're
still alive enough to move his eyes and
head before apparently dying stabbed
Williams didn't kill it the
cinematographers close-up tit for good
with us I'll see what I can do
yes thanks now try nestle in a few days
we'll all be nearly killed and have to
flee but for now sleep child you've done
nothing for which you should be ashamed
the only place is here now I'm going
back I'm a soldier it's my duty yep
nearly three our movie has time to
repeat basically the same argument they
had when he first enlisted also maybe
the title of this film actually refers
to Gabriel thankfully Heath Ledger gets
to avoid this obviously deadly battle
because he decided to go trespassing for
funsies even though Gabriel left a few
hours before Benjamin did Benjamin still
had enough time to catch up to Gabriel
find him in this house and Batman behind
him only Brigade - hardly react to the
obvious surprise of seeing his father
behind him no running back a lot more
importantly oh did you find him even if
you knew what unit he was in you'd have
to have shown up hours ago and stalked
him to show up here and now no this
extended bloody military hospital shot
is intended to make you puke - I can't
think of any other reason this shot
exists I usually trust the French to
keep their word that's Frances casual
triple hanging is casual also these
people had a church service before
cutting down these hanging victims we
are here to pray for the souls of those
men hanging outside why didn't you cut
them down before praying for them will
be kind of rips off Rudy but takes its
sweet-ass time doing so and I'm this
close to just adding 50 sins for
frustration so I'm holding off for now
with candle light like this it's a
wonder the swamp based hidden Spanish
mission manages to stay a hideout for as
long as it does world all men I created
equal unto God jesus H Christ having a
white male character in a Revolutionary
War movie say this to a black man made
my eyes were also hard I'm dizzy
yeah this woman cannot tell the
difference between fireworks and a ship
exploding she's wasted y'all I've come
to call on Anne movie makes Ann's father
death too needlessly pad the movie's
runtime holy crap the situation went
from I have come to calling your
daughter too I'm spending the night you
better sell me in so I don't touch your
daughter in like six hours
Gabriel is unaware of the situation
regarding his feet because he is unable
to taste ink for some reason I made this
for you to God of course to represent
the violence of my day-to-day life and
because I believe you're ready for guns
at the ripe old age of six she gave him
the ink tea twelve hours ago I've got a
simple goodbye kiss at this point
transferred that much ink into her mouth
my point is this smile is to Enki to be
believable this attack is what happens
when guerrilla revolutionary war
fighters get a taste of their own
medicine wait whose side am I on movie
continues to overestimate the range of
the flip-flop distort this is one of the
best scenes in the movie now shows up
with Cornwallis's dogs and bargains a
prisoner exchange even though he has no
British prisoners and after all is said
and done the prisoners are released and
the dogs leave Cornwallis and stay with
Gibson and Friends priceless my question
is how the fuck did they get those dogs
so bonded with them in a few days with
just mutant bones aren't dogs loyal we
never get any indication that Cornwallis
mistreated them or anything they just
apparently like Mel Gibson more than
they do Tom Wilkinson after three days
I've seen YouTube videos of real dogs
that freaked out when their army owner
returns home from active duty after
several years what gives this guy needs
a spyglass to see them riding 80 yards
away this is the single most useless use
of a telescopic device in film history
just eyeball that here I mean Jesus that
man and stalks me quite impressive for a
farmer with a pitchfork wouldn't you say
this guy flirts with insubordination so
hard you might as well be the anti
employee the month but to do so requires
the use of tactics but a somewhat queer
folks that will do an orchard whose
brutal form all as easily goes along
with this even though I have trouble
believing that given the immense power
of the British military burning a church
filled with townsfolk is the only
effective method for finding Benjamin
tell me about Ohio it's currently
inhabited by lots of natives you get to
kill with no repercussions you'll love
it what do you know about it
everything I can tell you the size of
his boot does he have family movie
thinks I need more reasons to hate this
guy and also things wants to kill
children is what's going to tick me up
another anger not when he's already
killed children including Benjamin
Martin's children in this movie already
we have coming thank God it Charlotte is
a light sleeper
these guys are seeking this family out
to kill them but they walk in all slow
and steady moving slowly is somehow
their friend
just open the door run upstairs and
slaughtery an idiot this movie does not
give British people a good name in the
area of battlefield intelligence this is
one of those movie moves where they just
give the finger to everyone the bad guy
was sure he was under there we as an
audience knew for sure he was under
there but then nope sometimes when we
weren't looking he got out I bet even
that kid himself is confused as to what
happened but good tension movie I guess
cheater also there is a huge obvious
shadow top right of the shot that the
evil guy should totally check out
because it's actually the child he
thought was under the table but he
totally doesn't and the kids just go
instead of saying I've never been here
in the secret tunnel before and don't
know the way that tunnel led them to
here right the kingside the house and in
full view of anyone paying attention
which this passing british soldier is
not doing this might be in contention
for the luckiest escape ever i'll have
to check my records god dammit gabriel
knew his skin to all these people hiding
behind the bush broke his rifle first
why because it's a movie you idiot and
roland emmerich wanted to make you think
for a moment these people had all been
captured logically damned I feel sorry
for her but this is merely the second
house we've seen her living in so she's
rich she'll be fine
seconds after this order the soldiers
peace out without having found anyone
that is one of those horrifying dolls
I've seen since that Seinfeld episode
where susan has a doll that looks just
like George's mother what did she say
she said that she loves here and misses
you why does he lie about this why not
just say she spoke and let Dad be happy
that she finally spoke I make up untrue
comments about her loving and missing
her father so that later when he sees
her he'll be even more heartbroken
Southington has a list of our men he's
burning our homes okay so maybe the
homes of these vigilante soldiers are
being burned well that's terrible and
tragic but more importantly who wrote
down a list of your names who gave it to
tavington you've been an off books rogue
outfit from the start only one of you
here are the inside could have written
down all the family names and addresses
of the participants knowing this British
asshole
killed children is not enough we
apparently also need to see dead
children on screen to get the point
finding out his family is dead leads
this guy to shoot himself in the head I
just want to point out that the movie
does nowhere near enough to show his
friends and fellow soldiers dealing with
witnessing that kind of trauma yeah sure
we got some sad faces
I'm telling you firsthand witnessing a
suicide or even its aftermath would a
person up why does the only recently
speaking daughter just trust her dad why
silly viewer we're never told obviously
some good stock on their father's side
hey remember when Benjamin said that to
Charlotte earlier I don't because that
happened 8,000 hours ago finally safe in
the african-american beach paradise this
family sleeps together and I do not know
how either of these adults in this shot
get any sleep at all given the
arrangement kids sure they're good
basically pretty much no matter what and
they move around a lot making the shot
even less believable oh wait he's not
asleep and she's not asleep but somehow
it feels even worse you once said when I
had a family of my own that I'd
understand you were right trying to tell
me something the timing of this girl's a
rival makes Gabriel a wizard like a
legit magical person I mean I love
CityTime this conversation so perfectly
I don't the director said hey let's have
you eat an apple in this shot and share
it with your son since everything about
this particular moment in the film and
its timing is actually an asshole thank
God the local clergyman was part of the
militia otherwise the ceremony would
have to have been officiated by some
internet certified under qualified
person like Joey Tribbiani also was
Gabriel traveling as a militia guy with
a white suit for marriage purposes or
did his Brides family bring that with
them so now perfectly guess his
measurements ancestry country no it's
not isn't that the point of those
three-hour movie I'm not me
she's right if she were her sister she'd
be dead wow it sure is convenient that
this guy's dead wife has such a rich hot
nurturing sister am i right this is what
they call over tidiness well every loose
end of a screenplay needs to be tied
office what I'm saying nice isn't she
hate them so much why did she even agree
to line up with the other so Oh screw
you a movie you blew your wad on this
emotional moment
ages ago I will not give in to my base
emotions just because you put a little
girl on screen it Oh for pete's sake Oh
someone give up for baby I did you would
have been better
what's worse these assholes showing up
just after Mel Gibson says this or them
showing up all of us we're ours do I get
the opportunity to kill a few redcoats
perhaps a few wounded ones when you're
not
haha yes let's only have morals when
they are convenient to the story
colonel tavington wishes to address the
whole village wheres honeymoon ever
oh you feel bad about your choices now
but not back when you add yourself with
the devil you do I don't care if you
were on Firefly the British asshole
burned the entire village but apparently
didn't think to come back by and check
for morning love once Benjamin is able
to find a small piece of jewelry in this
pile of soot ash and death that asshole
Gabriel took off after the British
murderers but only so recently has to be
easily followed it's almost a shame
Heath Ledger will always be most known
for the Joker because even though he
killed the Joker he was really good like
Brokeback Mountain and this movie how
the fuck did that guy just sense that
Gabriel was above him and about to kill
it
super-hearing and how did he know to
wait between the time Gabriel showed up
and the moment he decided to attack huh
Oh son that wasn't your fault
I was mine was Thomas his fault if we
really want to talk about it he was
going to decided to be a dumbass when it
was most important to not be a dumbass
so now you've lost both your two eldest
sons to this war keep going or give up I
think we know what he's going to choose
but only because it's a movie I don't
actually have a good transition shot
here boss so I guess we just fade to
black for a moment why I the men feel
they can justify death well suddenly
philosophical Benjamin asked your former
self that apparently utterly ravaged the
Native American outpost he might know
even though Benjamin spied that flag and
made up his mind yesterday he waited
dramatically before riding up today
bearing that flag for an emotional
moment also this is the brave hardiest
moment in this entire film
remember colonial Americans they can
never take off right on did we ever use
any normal bullets if I die I will die
ones rest for he was dying uncomfortable
there are two ways to skin that cat I'm
honored to have you with us oh I forgot
about how the Revolutionary War ended
bigotry and slavery hi foolin with the
OL we have a bunch of guys over this
hill you foolishly ran over routine
classic two whole minutes of marking
engine remains hyper-focused on
tavington yet no other British regular
comes up to kill or fight him Benjamin
tosses his gun aside because he now has
the ultimate weapon the American flag
the only time in the history of America
were waving a flag like this fired up
anything other than a college football
crowd Will Hunting himself could sit
down and calculate the odds Ben Martin
would ultimately square off with his
British asshole on the battlefield and
he would have called those odds
astronomical and yet here we are
SOLAS he did the same you thought I was
dead but I fooled you kill move on this
guy that this guy did to his son Gabriel
talked about coming full circle we named
him Gabriel not Thomas that kid was an
idiot
is more than is more counting fruits for
you want another like a disguise these
brutal tactics must stop things patron
shot this far down fast how can I hold
it all men are created equal when here
before me stands stinking the moral
carcass of the gentleman from Ohio
so clue when I was 17 I drank some very
good no
[Music]